[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition spéciale sur tv soixante dix
huit ans ce jeudi 2 avril émission
encore une fois consacrée à la pandémie
de coronavirus dans les yvelines
et 17e jour de confinement en france et
une situation pandémique malheureusement
toujours difficile dans le département
aux derniers chiffres publiés hier par
santé publique france le colis de 19
avaient fait 119 morts dans les hôpitaux
des yvelines elle 21 décès
supplémentaires donc en 24 heures
815 personnes étaient hospitalisées hier
sur le territoire 175 placé en
réanimation lé retour à domicile après
une amélioration de l'état de santé
continuent eux aussi de progresser à ce
jour 347 personnes ont pu quitter les
hôpitaux illinois et malgré ces retours
les placements tout de même dans les
établissements hospitaliers du
territoire certains patients dû être
évacuées vers des régions moins touchées
par le coronavirus pour libérer des
places de réanimation écoutez à ce
propos le préfet des yvelines
la situation est évidemment préoccupante
aujourd'hui 2 avril dans la mesure où
tous les lits de réanimation sont
occupés en dépit de la création de
nombreux lits de réanimation grâce à une
mobilisation exceptionnelle des médecins
des hôpitaux privés et publics mais le
fait est que tous les lits sont occupés
par des patients atteints du coc vite 19
et que plusieurs patients déjà été fait
évacuer vers des zones en france moins
touchée par l'épidémie notamment
hier quatre personnes sont parties à
brest et 6 sont partis à rouen et
d'autres personnes en réanimation vont
être évacués avant la fin de la semaine
c'est donc dire que la situation est
préoccupante du point de vue sanitaire
même si je le répète il y à une
mobilisation exceptionnelle de
l'ensemble des acteurs de la santé dans
le département des yvelines pour faire
face à la crise sanitaire et protéger
correctement le personnel soignant la
région ile de france a passé commande de
20 millions de masques les premiers sont
arrivés ce matin dans la région annonce
de la présidente de la collectivité
valérie pécresse via son compte twitter
un premier chargement a été livrée ce
matin à saint-ouen en seine-saint-denis
ville où se situe le siège de la région
ile de france
en complément de ses commandes des
entreprises et structures font également
don en ce moment de matériel médical
l'équipementier automobile valeo a
planté à la verrière notamment qui a
remis des protections à l'hôpital privé
de trappes reportage de wilfrid richy
patrick jacques de dixmude et nicolas
landry plus de 300 masques et 140
lunettes de protection en provenance du
site saint quentinois de l'entreprise
valeo vont équiper les médecins et
professionnels de santé de l'hôpital
privé de l'ouest parisien
un don effectué en milieu de semaine et
qui vient compléter ceux effectués dans
le reste de l'hexagone
il est normal pour valeo de contribuer à
cet effort de solidarité à travers les
dons comme les masques les lunettes pour
les équipes médicales et les hôpitaux
locaux
il s'agit d'un matériel de dépannage
tout du moins je l'espère en attendant
que les livraisons se fasse plus vus
régulièrement et en quantité suffisante
pour que nos soignants mais à bien leur
mission vitale est quasiment
réquisitionné qu'uniquement % tous les
braves ont été quasiment arrêtée au
profit du choix des patients covin
l'hôpital privé de l'ouest parisien peut
aussi compter sur la solidarité des
commerçants locaux qui déposent des
denrées alimentaires pour le personnel
sur le plan médical la clinique privée
kennedy à montélimar dans la drôme
annonce aussi avoir envoyé 12 soignants
vers l'établissement de trappes valeo de
son côté s'est associé au niveau
national avec air liquide le groupe psa
et schneider electric pour aider à la
fabrication de quelques 10000
respirateur d'ici la mi mai un
consortium lancé par le gouvernement
alors que de nombreux hôpitaux sont
aujourd'hui débordé de patients
gravement atteints par le cos vite 19
continuer la mission de service public
essentiel en cette période de
confinement pôle emploi restent
mobilisés pour accompagner au mieux les
demandeurs d'emploi avec des activités
qui sont dématérialisés les explications
de nicolas landry et de patrick jacques
de dixmude une zone d'accueil désertes
des espaces d'actualisation vide tous
les services de pôle emploi sont
dématérialisés depuis le début du
confinement
les quelques 700 conseillers yvelinois
reste tout de même mobilisé 80 %
augmentent nos conseillers sens sans
mobiliser soit en télétravail soit
mobilisables il travaille de chez eux
avec leurs propres moyens il appelle les
demandeurs d'emploi soit ils viennent en
agence mais pour des équipes très
réduite pour que le confinement soit
respectée aussi première mission a
assuré l'actualisation des situations
des demandeurs d'emploi yvelinois tout
cela à distance sans les accueillir dans
les centres
à l'heure où je vous parle les
demandeurs d'emploi qui ont l'habitude
de ça de s'actualiser chez nous 70% ont
fait leur actualisation
nous avons passé dès la semaine dernière
plus de 2000 appels pour les informer et
les travailler sur la manne de la
meilleure façon de faciliter leur
actualisation
nous allons à partir de demain et de la
semaine prochaine rappeler tout ce
qu'ils n'ont pas n'ont pas fait pour
assurer d'ici le 15 avril de leur
actualisation ce qui permettra leur
payement autres tâches permettre la
poursuite des différentes démarches pour
un retour à l'emploi formation
préparation à l'entretien rédaction d'un
cv
toutes ces activités peuvent être
réalisées sur la plateforme internet
emploie store tous nos services on
s'organise aujourd'hui pour que nos
prestations et nous il nous aide soit
celle qu'en peu dématérialisée avec nos
prestataires avec nos partenaires vont
être dématérialisées en proposera nos
demandeurs d'emploi des accompagnements
à distance sur leur projet travaillent
sur leurs projets et et des ateliers à
distance les services de pôle emploi
restent aussi mobilisées auprès des
entreprises afin d'assurer une
continuité dans l'accompagnement du
recrutement de certaines sociétés et les
commerces aussi sont forcément impactées
par la crise sanitaire le confinement
les oblige pour beaucoup à fermer
boutique pour soutenir les commerçants
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines a mis en place plusieurs
dispositifs
un groupe facebook tout d'abord moyen
pour les professionnels de se faire
connaître auprès des habitants et de
partager leurs initiatives et bonnes
pratiques
une carte interactive a est également
mise en place pour inciter à consommer
local elle permet de repérer les
commerces encore ouverts les plus
proches de chez soi agriculteurs
maraîchers qui peuvent demander à y
figurer avec gratuitement sur cette
carte interactive d'ailleurs on retrouve
notamment l'enseigne saveurs des
comptoirs qui reste ouverte à voisins le
bretonneux
son activité la vente de café et de thé
qui est malgré tout adapté à la crise
avec uniquement des prises de commandes
et des possibilités de retrait en
boutique
wilfrid richy patrick jacques de dixmude
et nicolas landry pas d'accès direct à
la boutique mais un retrait juste devant
la porte principale un système de drive
improvisé afin de permettre un maintien
de l'activité depuis le début du
confinement l'enseigne saveurs des
comptoirs s'est adapté et recentrer sur
l'activité de vente de thé et de café
j'avais un gros doute sur le fait que ce
soit ouvert mais bon en fait je me dis
que le café c'est quand même un produit
de première nécessité donc pourquoi pas
j'ai tenté ma chance à étant moi-même
artisans sur saint quentin en yvelines
je me dois de faire travailler d'autres
confrères artisans commerçants donc
c'est pour ça aussi que je viens dans
ces petites structures là déjà on l'a
fait pour nos clients ensuite on l'a
fait parce que il faut il faut que la
boutique puisse tourner on a déménagé
cette année l'année dernière ça fait un
peu plus six mois
donc c'était un gros projet avec des
gros enjeux donc aujourd'hui il faut
qu'on assure la pérennité de notre
entreprise
le manque à gagner est d'ores et déjà
importants avec un chiffre d'affaires
divisé par deux depuis trois semaines
est ce que certain c'est que d'une part
on n'a pas perdu une partie de notre
notre clientèle
toute la clientèle qui vient notamment
de de gérer 2
de d'assez loin pas forcément la
proximité même de la boutique qui ne
peut plus se déplacer aujourd'hui la
clientèle d'entreprises qui ne va plus
au bureau
malgré tout les dirigeants ont décidé de
limiter les recours aux aides mises en
place par l'état notamment les reports
de charges et une seule salariée est
aujourd'hui en chômage partiel
c'est sûr que par contre la reprise
risque d'être compliqué c'est un peu le
jir elle plus un inconnu dans cette
histoire c'est comment voilà comment le
leur tour gérait le dégonflement va
là-bas se presser mais c'est sûr que ça
aura des impacts économiques à moyen
terme puisque 20 tout l'argent qu'ils ne
rendent pas aujourd'hui dans les
entreprises
et puis chez les chez les particuliers
forcément ne se retrouvera pas sur le
sur l'économie demain donc c'est sûr que
ça sera la fin d'année 2010 2020 ce sera
forcément plus compliqué adaptation
également du côté des collectivités la
région ile-de-france tiendra par exemple
demain vendredi sa commission permanente
en téléconférence séance exceptionnelle
pour voter une mesure un fonds d'urgence
de 10 millions d'euros à destination du
spectacle vivant franciliens l'objectif
aider les structures qui font face à des
pertes économiques liées à la
billetterie et aux recettes des ventes
de spectacle une à deux sous réserve
d'un engagement de la structure à
maintenir l'emploi intermittents
initialement prévu en france au 20 mars
plus de 8600 dates ont été annulés 70%
de cette activité est basé en ile de
france
pour refermer ce journal une activité
qui vous occupera pendant cette période
de confinement c'est une soirée à
retrouver demain vendredi en direct live
sur la chaîne youtube samouraï tv c'est
à partir de 20h35 et c'est une diffusion
que vous pourrez voir du documentaire
best tricks autour d'une première
mondiale un triple salto arrière sur une
slackline et ça a été réalisée par le
verrier roi louis boniface on en parle
avec eux johan grignoux bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes vous aussi vers hyérois
et vous êtes le réalisateur de ce
documentaire qui dure 52 minutes déjà
louis boniface on le connaît bien sûr tv
60 18 mai pour les téléspectateurs qui
ne connaîtraient pas louis boniface qui
est il alors luis et un verrier roi
comme vous l'avez dit qu'ils installent
kleiner de base gymnaste de haut niveau
il a été en pôle espoir et en sortant de
son parcours de gymnastique s'est lancé
en sa klein et en l'espace de quelques
années il est devenu meilleur français
est aujourd'hui dans le top peut le dire
dans le top 10 mondial de slackline et
en quelques mots la slackline ça
consiste en quoi
alors la châtelaine on peut le dire
c'est du funambulisme acrobatique enfin
en tout cas la variante que louis fait
c'est du chai en bulles isma chromatique
donc l'idée c'est de faire des saltos et
des figurants tous genres sur sur une
sangle qui fait en général 5 cm
d'épaisseur et voilà en gros sa
consistance à et a enchaîné ses figures
là et essayer de d'enchaîner un maximum
de figures pour pour gagner un maximum
de points si on parle en termes de
compétition et donc le documentaire met
en lumière une performance le je disais
tout à l'heure un triple salto arrière
réalisé sur une slackline c'est ça c'est
une première mondiale qui est qu'il
réalise dans ce documentaire c'est bien
ça en fait
ce documentaire il est né après sa
première mondiale du triple salto avant
donc il a fait un triple salto avant
c'était le premier au monde à l'avoir
fait et avoir réussi en fait à partir à
6 envoyé un triple salto est arrivé à
six et la sueur dans ce documentaire on
a décidé de raconter toute l'histoire
pour réussir un triple salto arrière
donc cette fois il est assis et il sent
il se jette en arrière il fait une
triple rotation et il arrive à six sur
la slackline et voilà en fait ça raconte
un an un an de combat et d'entraînement
pour
réussir cette figure finalement qui est
pour laquelle en fait pour les pour les
deux figures il a obtenu des guinness
world records dont on a eu la
signification de cet organisme la qui
certifie les les premières mondiales et
un documentaire vous le confirme et
tourné en grande partie dans le
département des yvelines
c'est bien ça en fait on a tourné 90% du
documentaire ici si ce n'est plus
d'ailleurs je n'ai pas réellement la
proportion mais c'est majoritairement
dans les yvelines à la verrière un petit
peu aussi après le mesnil saint denis en
forêt est majoritairement ici à la
celle-saint-cloud 6 enfin voilà on a on
a tourné majoritairement dans les
yvelines
une dernière question le programme de la
soirée devant l'as compris diffusion de
ce documentaire mais vous prévoyez
d'autres choses pour cette soirée en
live alors c'est bien ça on va commencer
avec une petite présentation avec louis
du film du pourquoi on a fait ce film là
l'équipe qui a eu derrière
majoritairement j'ai tourné et monté
tout seul mais à la fin du processus
j'ai décidé de travailler des personnes
pour essayer de rendre le projet encore
plus beau et donc sur cette première
partie de soirée on parlera de tout ça
avant de lancer le film est enfin après
le film on reviendra après débriefer sur
sur nous notre ressenti par rapport au
film et enfin répondre aux questions des
personnes qui seraient là via un chat
sur sur youtube forcément une
réadaptation avec cette période de
confinement qui nous oblige tous à
rester chez soi c'est bien ça parce
qu'effectivement à la base l'idée était
de diffuser le film en salle à la
verrière on avait la possibilité de
diffuser le film en salles devant 300
personnes malheureusement ça a été
effectivement remis en question il ya
déjà un mois et voilà on a dû s'adapter
s'est trouvé de solution s'est posé la
question est ce qu on maintenait la
sortie du film parce que ça nous a pris
deux ans de travail quand même donc on
veut pas sortir le film n'importe
comment
on a décidé de le maintenir parce qu'on
voyait chaque homme est aussi une
opportunité effectivement de proposer un
contenu différent de ce qu'on peut voir
habituellement et de proposer à des
personnes qui sont du coup confiné qu'on
peut être le temps où il envie de voir
de nouvelles choses
merci wang regnault merci à vous et on
voit ce qui était d'ailleurs avec la
bande annonce de ce documentaire
n'oubliait pas soirée à retrouver demain
en live à partir de 20h35 sur la chaîne
youtube samouraï tv
la fin de cette édition spéciale belle
soirée à tous sur tv 78 je m'appelle
louis boniface j'ai 21 ans je pratique
la slackline freestyle l'objectif dans
la slackline c'est vraiment de de me
dépasser en réalisant des figures
vraiment improbable recherché vraiment
la performance tout en ayant conscience
de la casse par rapport à mon niveau
réel le triple arrière c'est c'est
vraiment au dessus du triple avant
six mois ce qui sera dit du genji
[Musique]
j'suis un code barre du haut parce que
c'est que d'emboîter j ces projets
permettent de vivre cent ans des projets
comme ça que tu donnes des objectifs tu
dis bah là je sais que je vais enchaîner
et ce qui est fou c'est que c'est pas
comme un contrat tu vois c'est pas comme
en cdd tu vois tu sais quand tu
commences mais tu sais pas quand tu
termines et ça ça ça apporte vraiment un
plus
[Musique]